just have monetized Beauty so much and
I'll even use myself as an example I'll
admit this like you're in an advantage
as a chick like you just get more
eyeballs like more more people want to
listen to you when you're a girl a guy
has to work 10 times as hard to get in
the same position as we do in media
um and I and I think we get into more
trouble when we start to just think it's
all by ourselves and we don't have any
advantage and you know
um it's not easier in life being a chick
I think it's easier when you know that
it is
um so Kappa says now they just need to
do this for all sports so again this is
what we're feeding into the delusion
that men and women are equal and again I
think there's a natural hierarchy in the
world guys God men women children and I
think the more we tell us women that
we're equal and that we're just as good
and just as powerful and and more
deserving than men I think that's when
evil really happens